what up reject nation it's your girl
sally aka sally lamonico aka salamander
now you can only call me salamander if
you subscribe you know we gotta be on a
nickname basis so uh please hit that
subscribe button it's completely free i
mean in this economy with inflation like
why wouldn't you just like have
something for free you know so if this
is your first time watching one of my
videos on this channel i'm doing a
marvel movie marathon where i go through
all of the marvel movies starting with
phase one all the way through phase four
because i have not seen most of them i
know shocking listen time just
got away from me i i guess you can check
out my previous videos i started with
iron man and today we are continuing
with iron man 2. this is super exciting
if you enjoyed this video please give it
a like it really does help the algorithm
it helps us out a lot it's like free
tipping like you're tipping out but like
it's free
just give it a like you know what i mean
if you would also like to watch my full
reaction it is on their patreon if you
go to patreon.com
the real rejects you can watch my full
reaction and you can even watch more of
greg and john which i know you want to
because they're great guys they got a
lot of full reactions on there tv shows
movies that aren't on their channel you
can also follow me if you want at
selling the monaco on instagram and like
i have a youtube channel so it'd be cool
if you like subscribe to that too and
lastly thanks to prepper for editing
together the highlights for this video
i'm very appreciative greg and john are
very appreciative thank you so much guys
now let iron man 2
commence
we had that vodka ready
same
[Music]
i can't tell if you had highlights or
just gray hair perfectly
perfect strands of gray hair
it's the fourth of july wait that's sick
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
there was just one guy in the audience
that was just like
and all the girls were screaming
[Music]
what does pepper potts think about that
and now making a special guest
appearance from the great beyond to tell
you what it's all about please welcome
my father
howard
everything is achievable through
technology
better living it reminds me of walt
disney
with the music look it's disneyland i'm
kidding
[Music]
this is larry hey the oracle of oracle
what a pleasure and i see it
larry king larry
was that stan
that was stanley
to turn over the iron man suit would be
to turn over myself which is tantamount
to indentured servitude or prostitution
depending on what state you're in
you can't have it
look i'm no
expert in prostitution of course not
you're a senator come on oh
ah
this is a disney movie let the record
reflect that i observed mr hammer
entering the chamber and i am wondering
if and when any actual expert will also
be in attendance i'm no expert i'd defer
to you anthony uh senator if i may
he called him anthony you know we live
in a world of grave threats threats that
mr stark will not always be able to
foresee okay
i wish that would happen in real life
not the robots
killing people but
if there was a hearing and that happened
that would be funny all right america is
secure you want my property you can't
have it but i did you a big favor
i have successfully privatized world
peace
i tried to play ball with these ass
clowns thank you mr stark
you buddy
oh my god if court hearings went like
that life would be pretty
interesting one thing i've proven is
that you can count on me
to pleasure myself
[Music]
bob the builder can he fix it
[Music]
wake up daddy's home welcome home sir
congratulations on the opening
ceremonies it was such a success this
was your seventh hearing
and may i say how refreshing it is to
finally see oh my gosh old school
youtube
you are running out of both time and
options
unfortunately the device that's keeping
you alive is also killing you
matt
what are you thinking
what what are you thinking hey i'm
thinking i'm busy and you're angry about
something the expo is a gigantic waste
of time i need to wear a surgical mask
until you're feeling better is that okay
that's rude
cut to 20 20.
yeah pepperoni i'm trying to run the
company stop trying to do it and do it
i'm not asking you to try to do it i'm
asking you to physically do it i need
you to do it i am trying to you're not
listening to me i'm trying to make your
ceo
i hereby
irrevocably appoint you chairman and ceo
of stark industries effective
immediately
mom i thought there'd be a legal issue
but actually i'm uh capable of
appointing my successor
my successor being you
take it just take it i don't know what's
the thing don't think drink oh the way
her eyes lit up girl yeah get that bread
and that robert johnny jrd
i just want to know what his beef is
[Music]
i promise you this is the only time i
will ask you to sign over your company
what's your name lady rushman natalie
rushman front and center coming to the
church i need her she's got everything
that i rule number one never take your
eye off your opponent
oh my god
get it bro
will that be all mr stark yes that will
be all
she's like get out girl
you're a competition i want one no
is he like extra
objectifying in this movie
mr musk
how are you congratulations on the
promotion thank you very much
those merlin answers are fantastic thank
you yeah good idea for an electric jet
that's elon musk better actor than amber
heard
christine everherd from vanity fair you
guys know hi yes
yes yes roughly
btw big story the new ceo of stark
industry he's like i [ __ ] her
yikes
this cannot happen absolutely i
understand how can i help you where's
happy he's waiting outside okay get him
i need help right away
[Music]
so did he just like kick out one of the
drivers like how did he
[Music]
what
that's messed up
hang on
[Applause]
y'all what is this what oh my god
[Music]
how is security not just like
well i yeah why would they
kind of broke his neck
oh
hopscotch
jump rope i wonder if he can double
dutch with those
[Applause]
okay someone else could have done that
oh my god
oh my god why they keep showing it
that's horrific bro
[Music]
she's gonna need therapy
how is he still alive
[Music]
you're gonna get electrocuted
[Music]
now they come right actually that's
pretty accurate i don't get a little
fine-tuning you could have made a solid
paycheck you could have sold it to north
you come from uh family of
thieves and butchers
you try to rewrite your own history
white people
if you can make god bleed then people
will cease to believe and they will be
blood in the water hey tony before you
go
palladium in the chest painful way to
die
i don't want to go home we're in europe
let's go to venice cipriani
remember oh yeah company retreat a
retreat during a time like this well i'm
just needing to recharge your batteries
and figure it all out
not everybody runs on batteries don't we
that was a good line
what
that
absolute pleasure my name is justin
hammer
i'd like to do some business with you
dig in what do we have today jack um we
have some salmon salmon so what he's
like
the only difference between you and i is
that i have resources you need my
resources
do you speak english because i can get a
translator very good man
very good man very cool
i want my board
you want a bird
is this a bird back in russia
fundamentals of the company are still
very very strong pepper pots drinking dr
pepper anton vanko was a soviet
physicist who defected to the united
states in 1963 his son ivan who is also
a physicist was convicted of selling
soviet era weapons great plutonium to
pakistan you all right yeah i should get
to my desk you had this in your body
i want to make iron man look like an
antique i want to go to that stark expo
i want to take a dump in tony's front
yard you know what i'm talking about
i could do that if this was your last
birthday party you're ever gonna have
how would you celebrate it i'll do
whatever i wanted to do
sir i personally guarantee that within
24 hours iron man will be back on watch
i don't know what to do you gotta be
kidding me
[Music]
thank you so much tony we all thank you
so much for such a
wonderful night and we're gonna stay
good keep touching our butt oh my god
what is happening the party's over then
again the party was over for me like an
hour and a half ago the after party
starts in 15 minutes if anybody trevor
doesn't like it
there's the door
oh what
my god
[Applause]
oh so this is where his friend is like
enough bro i'm only gonna say this once
get out
you don't deserve to wear one of these
shut it down give me a fat beat to beat
my voice
what is this script
put your hand down you think you got
what it takes to wear that suit put it
down you gonna take a shot put it down
[Music]
they could have killed each other oh my
god
major
let's take it inside the silver does
look pretty dope told you i don't want
to join your super secret boy band
no no no yeah i i remember you do
everything yourself
how's that working out for you i'm sorry
i don't want to get up from the wrong
foot do i look at the patch of the eye
where's the staff here that's not
looking so good you are not the center
of my universe i have bigger problems
than you in the southwest region to deal
with get him
oh god you're gonna
steal my kidney and sell it [ __ ] that's
lithium dioxide it's gonna take the edge
off we're trying to get you back to work
i've been looking for a suitable
replacement for palladium i've tried
every combination every permutation of
every known element well i'm here to
tell you you haven't tried them all
ivan
what's this
is that a helmet doesn't look like a
helmet to me drone better i like you i
got you the bird i'm
you said no problem but you also said
you couldn't find volunteers so he's
helping you
government wants suits like iron man you
understand don't get too attached to
things
i'm going to let go
this order get descended off my ass it's
functional fully mission capable he was
cold he was calculating he never told me
he loved me and never even told me he
liked me so it's a little tough for me
to digest when you're telling me he said
the whole future was riding on me and
he's passing it down i don't get that
he was one of the founding members of
shield what
i got a two o'clock wait wait wait wait
what's this you should have led with
that
remember
i got my eye on you
this face
is this what i think it is yes it is
talking about firepower what are you
talking to the right guy this is a
kinetic kill sidewinder vehicle with a
secondary cyclotrimethylene trinitramine
rdx burst it's completely elegant it's
bafflingly beautiful i call it the
ex-wife
oh my god whoever wrote this particular
script doesn't like women very much i'm
kidding
tony i built this for you
i'm limited by the technology of my time
but one day you'll figure this out and
when you do
you will change the world
my greatest creation
is you
and so sweet
i thought i was coming to basically
apologize but i'm not oh you didn't come
here to apologize that goes without
saying and i'm working on that
but i haven't been entirely uh up front
with you and i just want to try to make
good can i move this
what is it you're trying to achieve sir
new element
i heard you broke the perimeter uh yeah
that was like three years ago where you
been
you know what this is exactly what i
need to make this work
drop it drop it
perfectly level
initializing prismatic accelerator
[Music]
sir the reactor has accepted the
modified call
what the hell does that mean ivan this
is not what we agreed to okay you
promised me suits and then you promised
this is not what i wanted what do you
expect
there he is it's the birdman oh now you
like the bird you know what take the
bird
hey what'd the bird do
you give me suits that was our deal i
don't know if you're a genius or a fraud
i don't know what you are
see these guys they're your babysitters
they are not to be trifled with he could
easily kill both of them incoming call
with a blocked number sir phone
privilege just reinstated hey tommy are
you doing
what
you told me double cycles more power yep
what's up you want to run some tests run
them it tastes like coconut
metal
but as revolutionary as this technology
there will always be a need for man to
be present that was so dumb why would he
do that because now they're all just
gonna like
air force lieutenant colonel james rowe
[Applause]
yes king shut this down
you got trouble
tony there are civilians present i'm
here on orders let's not do this right
now all these people are in danger we
got to get him out of here you got to
trust me for the next five minutes yeah
i tried that i got tossed around your
house remember i think he's working with
vancouver
[Music]
he's a hacker you idiot you knew this
imagine
imagine
i'm locked on i have target lock on what
on you
bro
[Music]
what's going on what's happening the
software's been overwritten what what do
you mean it's been overrated
it's impossible he's so stupid
he'll kick his ass
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm not taking you anywhere fine you
want me to drive no i'm driving in the
car why is everyone so mean to the girls
in this movie
oh my god
no
[Music]
nice work kid
and you just leave him there with the
drone
[Music]
she's kind of like a matured kim
possible make sure my tube can possible
jerome's is communicating in its own
unique language we'll choose one and
focus on that have you tried russian
yes queen have your moment
so we're about to get wet on this ride
wait wait wait wait
nice that's actually really cool
he's gone
what are you doing
i'm rebooting rudy's suit
oh my god
[Music]
thank you very much agent romanov well
done with the new chess piece yes for
the moment i'm not dying what do you
mean you're not dying did you say you're
dying is that you
i was going to tell you i didn't want to
you were going to tell me you really
were dying you didn't let it why didn't
you tell me that i was good
see that yeah yeah nice
jeez
get down
why didn't you just do that before
that's your guy here
she's my place under arrest
are you kidding me behind your back sir
i'm trying to help no you suck you
started to think like a ceo taking out
the competition i like that you think
you're making a problem for me i'm gonna
make a problem for you i'm gonna be
seeing you again real soon
he's he's a villain but he's not a very
likable villain you coming with us no
i'm gonna stay till the park is clear
okay
heads up you got one more drone incoming
this one looks different
is it ivan
[Music]
good to be back
oh this ain't gonna be good
use the lasers oh
i'm gonna bust his bunker with the
ex-wife
[Music]
[Music]
nice
you lose
all these drones are rigged to blow we
got to get out of here man all bombs
girl run don't just stare at it
honestly if they didn't have lights he
could have killed all of them
oh my god i can't take this anymore you
can't i can't take this look at me my
body literally cannot handle the stress
i i quit i'm resigning
that's it what
what did you just say
you're done you don't have to make any
excuses you deserve better hmm thank you
for understanding yeah yeah let's let's
talk uh let's talk clean up i'll handle
the transition it'll be easy okay what
about the press because you only have
the job for a week that's gonna assume
well with you it's like dog years i mean
it's like the president
okay
i think it was weird
you guys look like two seals fighting
over a grape
i
had just quit yes you don't have to do
that i i heard the whole thing you
should get lost i was here first get a
roof
agent romanov's assessment of you
personality overview mr stark displays
compulsive behavior prone to
self-destructive tendencies i was dying
textbook
narcissism
recruitment assessment for avenger
initiative iron man yes i got to think
about it read on tony stark not
recommended how can you approve
me but not approve me rody and i are
being honored in washington it is my
honor oh my god
distinguished awards to lieutenant
colonel james rhodes and mr tony stark
who is of course
a national treasure
i love it
[Music]
so i'm a ding dong dummy and i
well first of all gray didn't tell me to
watch the end credits but like i should
have known i knew there were end credits
that i just
spaced this is a different setup but i'm
going to be watching the end credits of
iron man 2 right now so let's fix my
mistakes of the past
i see what they did there that's
exciting that just went right into uh
right into what was next so you'll be
seeing in my throat reaction i have the
same outfit on hopefully i get a little
bit more of a reveal
for things that i don't know that are
coming
since filming this so
yay
well that was iron man 2. so i would say
as a movie overall
there was a lot going on i feel like
this definitely served as a big setup
movie for the avengers that was really
interesting there was just so many
different things going on but i
definitely can see how important this
movie is for iron man to be
a part of the avengers so that was
interesting i did like the additional
characters that were in this movie you
got i know she's black widow eventually
and then nick fury and um i don't
remember his name
that was really fun to see a bunch of
new characters i thought that
i then
was such a fascinating character for me
because he technically didn't have many
lines but every time ivan was on screen
i definitely wanted more
of his character because mickey rourke
did such a good job a lot of his moments
were just facial expressions and you
could kind of read him and see what he
was going to do next just by not saying
anything which i thought was
really great um as an actor he just did
such a good job i just i wanted to see
more of him actually and the ending just
was so abrupt with him that also they
didn't even use lasers on him there's so
many like things about this movie that i
felt like maybe aren't like plot holes
but you know when you're watching a
scary movie and you're like oh that's so
dumb why did they do that like i had a
lot of moments watching this movie it
did seem really long i don't know if the
first one the first one was definitely
the same around the same length but for
me the first one just felt way more fast
paced just like boom boom boom like
getting to the point and i felt like
with this movie
i had a lot of slow moments and it was
kind of like a slow build
and then at the end it was just like
boom boom boom boom boom done so that
was
different um this yeah again this movie
just seemed like more of a setup movie i
have heard that iron man 3 is a lot of
people's favorite out of all out of the
three iron man movies so i am really
excited to see that one and to see kind
of like how this movie sets up for the
best iron man movie
um so that was interesting i feel like
tony stark was different in this movie i
mean obviously he was dying throughout
the movie but he just seemed a little
different he seemed definitely a little
more
carefree obviously his confidence level
i feel like seemed to be a little lower
as well so his spark was kind of gone
but i feel like he got it back towards
the end same with pepper pots i feel
like she was just mad the whole entire
movie like that also kind of felt like
it came out of nowhere she was pissed
off in the whole movie and that and
they kiss i definitely would have loved
to have seen more of like
maybe like i don't know like i don't
know why he was hiding the fact that he
was dying from her like obviously it
adds conflict for the characters
obviously he wouldn't want to worry her
but i feel like he should trust her out
of everybody since she did kind of like
save his life in the last movie-ish so
um i think it would have been a little
more interesting if she knew
in terms of action i loved the fight
sequence between
um tony stark and his friend because the
one at the at his birthday party
because obviously that did set up you
know their
heroic dynamic at the end in the finale
but i liked that one because it it was
just more interesting to watch i feel
like than the last action sequence um
even though i didn't know how they were
going to fight off all of the drones it
seemed a little easy but like the fight
between them
there was just so much buildup between
the two characters and
uh i just thought that was unique for a
fight sequence um in comparison to the
ending
sam rockwell's character
i'm horrible with names like remembering
names from movies if it's not like in
your face the hammer uh was his last
name right he's an amazing actor by the
way like everything i see him in he just
knocks it out of the park and he played
such an annoying [ __ ] in this movie
that i'm like you did
you did the job
um i know some people complain about
there being multiple villains in movies
i know people complained about it with
uh spider-man 3 they complained about it
with the amazing spider-man 2. i feel
like this one also kind of had that
dynamic where there was kind of like
multiple
villains and
and
they didn't really know where the story
was gonna go with the villains
um so i feel like that also got
confusing like who
i don't know it's hard to do i feel like
it's hard to do a movie where there's
two villains and kind of balance it out
this one i feel like something was
missing with it a little bit um but
i still really enjoy watching all the
characters
perform together i feel like there were
a lot of scenes in this movie that felt
really off the cuff like a lot of the
dialogue sometimes uh like just felt
kind of like it was ad-libbed or or
improved into the movie which i actually
really liked i i like when uh moments
and movies seem really like raw where
they were like when he was just like can
i move this and she's like no you can't
move stuff like that i don't even know
if it was in the script it would be
funny it was like brilliant it was in
the script but it was just something on
set that you improvise i wouldn't be
surprised but i love moments like that
because it it makes you forget you're
watching a movie it just looks like
you're seeing two people interact
genuinely in a moment where they have um
it it's a special quality no matter what
is going on you cannot take your eyes
off that person every word they say
every gesture you're interested in
do i have it
yeah i don't know overall
uh this movie just made me excited to
see what is going to happen with all the
other characters and i think it was a
great introduction i did notice captain
america's shield right in it he was like
oh oh yeah i've been looking for that
thanks i need it and it was just
a level for
his project which was funny
so
and i don't know if they're gonna have
any more scenes
with the dad um tony stark's father
because i feel like
that also didn't seem fleshed out enough
like i would love to see more
of maybe flashbacks or something
of tony stark as a kid and then dynamic
between him and his father like that
would be
a really that was a subject that i was
hoping they would explore more in the
movie but um maybe they explore it in
another movie i feel like that would
explain
tony stark's personality a little bit
more
and would give a little more
heart to
his character
and
like the moment when his dad was like
this is all for you i feel like i would
have felt
like it was such a like sweet moment i
feel like i would have felt it more if
there was something
in the beginning
between him and his father like as a
flashback when he was a kid i don't know
but
um i had a lot of good moments though
that i think
there just could have been more but then
i feel like also there could have been
scenes that could have been cut and it
would have been fine i don't know how to
describe it because it was like
kind of a slower
movie um for the first hour i would say
so
anyway
that was iron man 2. i hope you enjoyed
my reaction and my honest review on the
movie
and uh yeah tune into the rest for phase
one i still have to watch thor iron man
well i guess iron man 3 isn't in
i don't know what phase that's in but
i'm really excited to get to iron man 3
so the rest are going to be thor captain
america and the avengers so i'm super
excited
thanks again for watching hit that
subscribe button if you enjoyed hit that
notification bell if you uh want to know
when i post the other ones and uh yeah
give it a like thanks for watching this
with me and i'll see you next week bye
[Music]